good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday but instead of doing news today
we're doing parts four of them part one
Chicago nerdfighters if you live in or
around Chicago I will be there this
Thursday morning at 11:00 a.m. for a
huge awesome nerdfighter gathering
tickets are free it's at the Herald
Washington library more info in the
sidebar
thank you just occurred to me that I
said if you live in Chicago I'm going to
be in Chicago on Thursday implying that
if you don't live in Chicago I will be
somewhere else on Thursday but in fact
I'll be in Chicago regardless I mean one
of the ways that we are not like
electrons is that my position in space
is not dependent upon your position in
space any one electron jokes no moving
on part to my old friend Harry Potter
Hank I didn't see the Harry Potter movie
on midnight of opening day like you did
but I went to see it last night with the
Yeti and we were sitting there like 30
minutes before it started and the
theater was filling up and I was like
I'm so excited about the Harry Potter
movie I get to see little of good and
I'm gonna cry at the end and then I
really liked the movie because it was
funny but it was also sad and it didn't
tell destructive lies about teenage
sexuality like some other movies I've
seen recently and Ron Weasley has gotten
so buff I mean Hank the movie was great
but the 30 minutes before the movie
started was what I loved about being a
nerd because nerds like us are allowed
to be on ironically enthusiastic about
stuff we don't have to be like oh yeah
that purse is okay or like yeah I like
that band's early stuff
nerds are allowed to love stuff like
jump up and down in the chair can't
control yourself love it Hank when
people call people nerds mostly what
they're saying is you like stuff which
is just not a good insult at all like
you are too enthusiastic about the
miracle of human consciousness speaking
of the miracle of human consciousness
part three artificial intelligence so
Hank there's this website that a lot of
nerdfighters have been talking about the
last few days basically it's the game 20
questions except instead of playing a
person you're playing an artificial
intelligence so you think of like an
animal or a mineral or a vegetable or a
person or a Doctor Who character and
then over the course of 20 questions the
computer program figures out what you're
thinking of and I will say that it's
astonishing how often this computer
program is right
but when it messes up it messes up badly
for instance I tried it with puppy-sized
elephants and a lot of the questions
were really difficult to answer like it
asked me if it was a mythical animal and
I was like puppy-sized elephants aren't
mythical animals they're animals in what
I consider pre-existence but I thought I
did a fair job of answering all 20
questions and then it guessed unicorns I
mean Hank I was thinking the puppy sized
elephants the most outrageously
wonderful creature not currently in
existence and it guessed unicorns which
everyone knows were left off the ark for
a reason
unicorns it's despicable anyway Hank I
also tried to get the artificial
intelligence to guess you and I answered
all of the questions completely honestly
the only one I struggled with was
whether or not you have a substance
abuse problem because I had a difficult
time deciding whether or not corn dogs
constituted a substance ok before I tell
you I want you to close your eyes and I
want you to imagine the one guy you most
do not want this artificial intelligence
to think you are ok Hank are you ready
they guess you were Perez Hilton yeah
part 4 nerdfighters do you have any
questions about love or romance and by
romance I mean nerd man's if so leave
them in comments Hank I've said it
before and I'll say it again nerd life
is just so much better than regular life
nerdfighters Hank I'll see you on
Tuesday